- [Narrator] The world's
most famous escape artist,
Harry Houdini.
He thrilled audiences
with dazzling illusions
and death-defying stunts.
This mastermind was from
here, Budapest, Hungary.
A city obsessed with escaping
and the escape legacy still
continues, thanks to this guy.
- Welcome to ParaPark.
Escape rooms, find the clue,
solve the riddle, crack the code.
These team building puzzles are popping up
all over the planet.
In fact, here in Budapest,
there are over 80 of them.
But back in 2010, escape
rooms didn't exist.
It was only ’til this
man thought up the idea.
- His speciality was playing
problem solving computer games
but then.
- So within three months,
Attila had quit his job,
found a space in Budapest
and opened the world's first escape room.
- An escape room works like this:
You and your friends are locked
in a room for 60 minutes.
You are then tasked with finding clues
and solving puzzles to unlock the door,
and thus escape that room.
- So if you ever find yourself in Budapest,
and you're stuck inside one
of its many escape rooms, like,
let's say the Mob House or a jail cell,
just remember to thank Attila.
One of the latest in this
cities launch edition
of Getting out of Hairy Situations.
(bright music)